doctor can we talk about cancer a little
bit um
various types out there what are some of
the things that you've
seen in terms of your patients and what
some of the things that you've been able
to do
a better thing to talk about in
relationship to well i will talk about
that
right a better thing to talk about
however
is the relationship between profits and
cancer
in the united states and there was a
study that was published i believe it
was in 1994.
it was a 12-year program 12-year study
they looked at adults
who had developed cancer as an adult not
childhood cancer but adult cancer right
and this is the main
types of cancer that we get here in the
united states
they did a meta-analysis of these people
all around the world who developed
cancer as adults for 12 years and were
treated with chemo
and they looked at the results and they
published the results
in the journal of clinical oncology and
the results
of the time chemotherapy does not work
of the time it doesn't work so why is it
still used
it's one reason and one reason only
money
if you go to a medical doctor an md with
a sinus infection and that doctor
prescribes an
antibiotic he gets no financial kickback
now if he prescribes 5000
you know of that antibiotic in one month
the drug company that makes it might
send him to cancun for a conference
right but he gets no direct remuneration
it's not with
with chemotherapeutic drugs it's
different
chemotherapeutic drugs are the only
classification of drugs
that the prescribing doctor gets a
direct cut of
so if your doctor prescribes
chemotherapy for you here's how it goes
more or less
the doctor buys it from the
pharmaceutical company for
five thousand dollars sells it to the
patient
for twelve thousand dollars insurance
pays
nine thousand dollars and the doctor
pockets the four thousand dollar
difference
and there ought to be a lot the only
reason
chemotherapy is used is because
doctors make money from it period it
doesn't
work 97 of the time
if ford motor company made an automobile
that exploded 97 percent of the time
would they still be in business
no this is the tip of the iceberg
of the control
that the pharmaceutical industry has on
us
we most people have no idea of this at
all now i wrote a book
it's called the md emperor has no
clothes right
in my book i have a bulleted list of 10
questions
that every cancer patient should ask
their doctor
10 questions i've had patients
kicked out literally kicked out of the
oncologist's office
because the doctor was pee owed that the
patient was asking him these questions
and these are just common sense
questions
cancer treatment in the united states we
have lost the war on cancer
we have lost the war on cancer why
because cancer is not a reductionistic
phenomenon
cancer is a holistic phenomenon and when
you try to bring
a reductionistic methodology like drugs
and surgery to bear on a holistic
phenomenon
you will completely miss the boat each
and every time you cannot do it
medical doctors are like colorblind art
critics
they can see that that's a boat they can
see the black and white outline
but they're completely blind to all of
the colors and textures
that make up the substance of the thing
it's no difference with cancer the
reason that
people get cancer in the united states
and the reason that we have completely
lousy outcomes
is because medical doctors are driving
the research bus
when women get together and do a 5k run
for breast cancer all of that money do
you think any of that money goes to
nutritional research do you think
any of that money goes to homeopathic
research or acupuncture or traditional
chinese medicine
or naturopathic research no all of it
goes to drugs and surgery
which do not work
now why aren't those women running for
selenium
if every girl in this country took 200
micrograms of selenium
in one generation we'd eliminate breast
cancer by 82 percent that's a big number
why aren't we doing that because
medicine in the united states is a
for-profit industry
and most people are completely unaware
of this and most
people bow down to the altar
of md directed high-tech medicine at
their own
demise